So we had a super busy day yesterday, the
last three of the roughly, Oh, I don't know,
14 hours or so
content that we did yesterday in addition
to the impeachment hearings was democratic
presidential debate number five. This one
was on MSNBC. They no longer even pretended
to really even try to hear from every candidate
on this stage. Equally, I believe Tom Stier
spoke two to three times. Andrew Yang, maybe
three or four. I think Tulsi Gabbert about
the same amount of time. And I understand
it. I mean this stage at this point is filled
with people who have no chance of being the
nominee. And it's important to hear from the
people who we might actually vote for who
might actually have a shot of winning. But
I still think that the solution then is make
the debate requirements tougher to meet. Don't
keep putting 10 people on the stage when half
have no shot, at least half, have no shot,
and mostly ignore them other than going to
them every once in a while.
But nonetheless, yesterday's debate featured
a whole bunch of missteps and had some funny
moments. But basically I don't think it will
make a difference to anyone's polling in any
serious way. It might hurt Biden a tiny bit,
might help Buddha judge a tiny bit. But otherwise
it's basically what was expected. And as I've
said before, the further into the primary
we get, the less each debate will have the
possibility of significantly moving the polls.
Now on foreign policy. And I tweeted about
this, it was really a fiasco back when, um,
uh, Andrew Yang still paid attention to me
before he started ignoring our show. I had
discussed with him foreign policy is what
separates the knowledgeable from the clueless
in debates of length because it's much easier
on domestic policy to have more than just
a bullet point or two without really know
anything and knowing anything.
Whereas on foreign policy it becomes much
more obvious. You don't know anything. And
if in a debate they ask a specific pointed
foreign policy question as they did yesterday
and what was, there were some wacky questions
like asking Bernie if he supports or denounces
what random people at some of his rallies
chanted. Um, other than some weird things
like that, it was actually a pretty well run
debate, skipping introductory statements with
smart and they asked some of these pointed
foreign policy questions and it became very
clear that a lot of the people on the stage
either don't have a clue or don't want to
say what their positions are. And they reflexively
go into just attacking Donald Trump, which
happened last night a lot. And I hate to say
this because I'm not supporting them and I
don't think that they are Progressive's the
people who actually answered the foreign policy
questions yesterday without just going into
bullet points or attacking Trump were Joe
Biden and Amy Klobuchar.
Amy has no shot. Biden has a shot, but he's
very centrist, not a progressive, but they
actually answered the foreign policy questions.
In addition to skipping opening statements,
the moderators did a pretty good job of exposing
that. A lot of the candidates lacked deep
knowledge on a variety of issues that includes
foreign policy. And I have said it before,
at this point in the game, there's a ton of
anti-Trump stuff in, in uh, in the impeachment
hearings. The debates can't be about, here's
why Trump is bad. One strange moment was when
Elizabeth Warren was asked if we should have
a bigger military and she said yes. I think
she was sort of confused almost by the question,
but here's how she answered.
Only about 1% of Americans serve in the United
States military right now. Should that number
be higher? Yes, I think it should be.
So this was weird because we already have
by far the biggest military way bigger than
we've ever, uh, than we would ever need. And
Warren is saying she wants more people in
the military. Now later she went on to talk
about, I think realizing that her answer wasn't
the best and her campaign clarified. Well,
she's talking about the peace Corps and volunteer
opportunities and that type of thing. Still
a very strange way to answer the question,
if that's what you mean. Yes. We need more
people in the military. Funniest moment was
Cory Booker telling Joe Biden that his position
on cannabis as a gateway drug was so weird
that Booker thought Joe Biden must have been
high when he said it.
I have a lot of respect for the vice president.
He is sworn me into my office as a hero this
week. I hear him little resay that I don't
think we should legalize marijuana. I, I thought
you might've been high when you said it.
[inaudible] marijuana, marijuana
country is already legal for privileged people.
It's actually a funny line and Booker had
an okay night other than having no chance
whatsoever. And you know his politics being
what they are on the optics, which is what
matters. Booker actually did. Okay. One of
the strangest moments for Joe Biden was, I
miss heard what he said as Joe Biden saying
he was the first black woman in the Senate,
which of course was not what he said, but
what he actually said was that he had the
support of the first black woman in the Senate,
which created a weird dynamic with Kamala
Harris on the stage who said something like,
I'm the other one and I'm here. It got weird.
Take a look.
It's for me because they know me. They know
who I am. Three former chairs in the black
caucus, the only black African American woman
that ever been elected to the United States
Senate. A whole range of people. Now I point
true
[inaudible] to
be vice president who is because of my relationship,
long standing relationship, the black community.
I was part of that coalition.
Yeah, so that was interesting. A very strong
moment for Andrew Yang was saying, we need
to designate white supremacist violence as
domestic terrorism. He got a good reaction
to that. Understandably. He should.
Mr. Yang, what would you do about the issue
of white supremacists?
First we have to designate white supremacist
terrorism as domestic terrorism so that the
department of justice talk to an anti hate
activist named Christian pitcher Leni who
told me about how he was radicalized over
a 10 year period
and he's right and he mentions Christian peach
Alenia who's been a guest on the show actually,
and who I know. He was recently in Boston.
A good moment for yang, one of the few that
he got. He did not get a lot of chance to
speak yesterday. One of the bigger moments
of conflict was Kamala Harris. Going after
Tulsi Gabard big time. Take a look.
Senator Harris, any response? Oh, sure.
Um, I think that, um, it's unfortunate that
we have someone on the stage who is attempting
to be the democratic nominee for president
of the United States, who during the Obama
administration spent four years full time
on Fox news criticizing president Obama about
full time, full time criticizing people on
this stage as affiliated with the democratic
party when Donald Trump was elected, not even
sworn in, buddied up to Steve Bannon to get
a meeting with Donald Trump and the Trump
tower fails to call a war criminal by what
he is as a war criminal and then spends full
time during the course of this campaign. Again,
criticizing the democratic party.
It wasn't attack but it fell sort of flat.
But maybe that's because, I mean, listen,
when I want to hear about the specifics of
how Warren and Bernie will implement and pay
for their health care plans, and then I see
someone pulling 4.3% attacking someone, pulling
2%. It's hard for me to really care that much
about that. And then you wonder why aren't
people who with a shot at winning actually
talking policy here, it's hard to get super
excited about these attacks and know a lot
of people loved Tulsi on it. And then a lot
of people said, look at, look at Camila smacking
down til I was like, why aren't we hearing
from people with a shot? One other funny moment,
Andrew Yang was asked, what would you say
to Putin on your first call as president of
the U S and here's what he had to say.
Mr. Yang, if you in the 2020 election, what
would you say in your first call with Russian
president Vladimir Putin?
First I'd say, I'm sorry, I beat you.
[inaudible]
sorry. Okay, so listen, this debate was competitive
in that many people did well enough. I don't
believe anybody was hugely damaged. I don't
think anybody made any big progress. There
were no real kill shots as I call them. The
one thing I can sort of think of, uh, was
a Cory Booker saying, I thought Joe Biden
was high when he said marijuana is a gateway
drug. It was funny, but it's widely and consequential.
Biden's position is just wrong. Uh, and Booker
has no shot. Now, one thing that is really
insane and infuriating is that Tom Stier was
on the stage. A lot of people forgot because
by the end of the Bay, the debate, he wasn't
talking. It seemed like he was, you know,
at that point, trying to get his parking validated
and get on out of there. But Tom Stier has
spent $50 million of his own money to pull
1% and get himself on the debate stage.
He has no shot. He never did. But think about
what he could have done with that $50 million.
If, if Tom Stier said, I'm not gonna run,
but I'm willing to put 50 million into the
2020 election, he could've put 50 million
into the five key Senate races that Democrats
need to take over control in 2020 of the Senate,
he could have fixed the water problem in Flint,
Michigan, which is still a problem. He could've
put 50 million into voter registration drives
to increase turnout and fight voter suppression
in 2020 which could help get rid of Donald
Trump. My point is almost any other use of
Tom Steyer's, $50 million would've left Democrats
better off than simply having another guy
pulling 1% on the debate stage. Let me know
if you believe this debate will move the needle
for anyone. Again, the longer this goes, the
less any one debate will move the needle.
Unless somebody really gaffes. We need fewer
people on the stage. And the next debate number
six is on December 19th it's the day before
we start our winter break, so we will be around
for that debate and streaming live. So far,
six candidates have qualified for that one.
Biden, Sanders, Warren, Buddha, judge Harris,
Clover char. You've got Tom Stier and Andrew
Yang pending. Nobody else has met any of the
requirements, so hopefully we will be down
to six or at the most, maybe seven
by the next debate. Let me know. Winners,
losers. What did you think? I'm on Twitter
at D. Pacman. The show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show,